okay for people who are joining this
livestream it is our first live stream
of 2019 and this is a meeting about
language completeness and consistency
for often language these are all things
that will be after version 12.04
things that have come up and we can talk
about them all right image effects plus
random seating what on earth is this
this is a continuation from last time so
if you if you open up the little
subsection there right we looked at the
various functions to take random seating
and the overwhelming majority take one
two three four block random for very
obvious reasons they inherited so do so
does net rain and we decided to change
classify and predict mesh net train they
don't remember exactly what the
reasoning was for net train and its
friends but that's sort of a coherent
cluster okay all right so word cloud and
image effect are the two cases well
actually sequence predictor function
generating random elements there's a
property called the next random element
or yeah I mean the sequence predictor
function is probably miss named there's
anybody from machine learning here no I
don't think so by the way that was a
really slow that's this is twelve point
oh that was a really slow start up if
somebody could again report this that
the the first time you think you okay um
right so we're so random next element so
sequence predictor so the surrounding
seating is only used for one property
which is random next element I don't
have an opinion about this whether it
should be repeatable or not probably not
repeatable breakers right cuz there's
next element which is the most likely
one and then random next element is you
know randomly sample from some
probabilities of the next element
yeah I mean I agree that that it
probably so automatic means what it
means it's receded every time or it
means it's correct so it's locally
receded but it whatever it is seeded as
is not does not survive the end of
sequence predictor function correct
correct
okay let's block random basically
basically right so we could change this
in the future to none if we don't want
it to even block but no no no it should
block I think why is this property
different from you know random variate
or random sample I think this is miss
named and I think sequence predictor
function will probably get revised
probably my guess but that's not for
this meeting because we don't have the
right people here okay okay let's come
to I assume you have shadi do we have
shadi here yes um okay so word cloud and
image effect I have to say I think that
word cloud should be one two three four
okay that I don't have an objection
right that's only as well for random
orientations of the words that we need
random CD image effect are you saying
that for word cloud in general is
deterministic yes
okay so let's understand what you mean
by random okay so because you see my
comment there that were claims to be
automatic although we haven't generated
an example where it actually has an
effect so okay Rev page or if you
generate one we have worth orientation
option and that option can take the
string random as a setting where the
orientation of the words are randomly
selected
gosh this needs to be all of these anti
value things need to be updated by the
way is that consumer or all of the
things that work this way should presume
will be updated to use entities um okay
so now this case which entities just out
of curiosity well I assume that this one
here would be that country data
open/close would be that would turn into
um I would assume countries
and I would assume let's just try it I
would assume that the word cloud that we
would get would be the same if not then
we're embarrassed well so far as I can
tell oh yeah it looks the same and
notice it's deterministic okay so let's
let's look here at um word orientation
right arrow is that the zero one called
why doesn't that autocomplete that by
the way that was an autocomplete failure
did you see that the word is patient
okay so let's go like this and come on
wake up okay there it is okay so now the
claim is if we do this again we will get
a different pattern
well I have to say I'm not totally
opposed to this being automatic I'm
being different each time given that you
asked for random what's that yes I I
want it well I was amused by your
response I was thinking I wonder if if
ten random seating should really be a
top-level option and not an option to a
sub option to word orientation how can
it be a sub option you mean you mean
random or that right it looks like a
method option so it's lists random
random seating error whatever it's not
stupid that wouldn't be stupid I mean
this isn't this is not an experimental
function so that would be a I mean it's
a compatible change actually so okay so
look in the documentation here um at the
very least let's change that
documentation to say and I think that
will that will help bum cauterize this
at least if we change that document here
let me let me just do it um I'm just
updating I don't know when I last did
this actually I just want to change it
to say specify the random seed for
random word orientations okay so in the
case of image effect it's like the
salt-and-pepper randomness or whatever
all their noises yes okay it might need
a documentation change but I think
that's um I'm sorry it's just taking a
moment to update here there we go okay
then let's go ahead and that was word
cloud
I think we should just say specify the
seeding for random word orientation and
then when we get to the word orientation
um we should say with word orientation
arrow random the option random seeding
specifies how random choices should be
seated well it's not just word
orientation goes to random presumably
since at least the last three syntax is
there indicate randomness oh I see but
I'm wondering shadi does this horizontal
vertical deterministic or is that also
no that's the deterministic I'm being
told
again it doesn't have to be we can make
that non deterministic whether we place
because that's also a choice between two
orientations wait wait wait wait wait
wait what are you talking about here
there third one horizontal vertical this
string horizontal vertical well so what
are you saying is so you're saying
um okay that's at least something that
so so what are you telling me that that
the random seating thing will also work
for horizontal vertical I'm just trying
it now because simply bad means a random
choice between actually that is
non-deterministic as well that's a
random choice between zero and 90
degrees okay
um okay so okay represents rotating
represents words rotated
counterclockwise by theta 1 radians um
okay
for all settings other than horizontal
and vertical there is randomness you
know the option random seating option
kind of seating option through word
cloud can be used to determine that make
sense to people right although although
I mean it's if I'm going to go
legalistic on you it's not completely
correct for the last forum but if if you
only have one angle in your inner list
see see I was gonna go the other way and
say that you just ignore horizontal
vertical and there your randomly
choosing out of one set you know one
element sets and so
yes yeah
actually is there a reason why just
theta is is right you can just give it a
naked number which is interpreted as an
angle which is not in that table it's so
- make all words be in that tab a a B of
that orientation does that work
yep I just trade it okay
well then so we should add here
something that says we should add a line
here is that correct Jody for all
settings allowing a choice of angle I
think that's better
yeah okay
random choices of angle okay
okay all right that's that
okay image effect do we have to worry
about what image effect says
you
yeah I tend to think we should not worry
about the site I tend to think are we
totally weird to get repeatable
readiness for image effect okay do you
agree totally okay you can can read
thick sorry I a you need to disappear
before I could finish reading it could
we take another look at the image effect
a major effect yeah just what do you
want to see this part right so we have
color styling color vision so does this
only affect the noise effects or we
don't even see there isn't something
called pseudo random so does this only
affect the pseudo random I think so I'll
have to check the thorne frame to see if
that is also randomly see there but that
that's the only other one that could be
randomly see all the other ones
soren frame on their framing effects the
second torn torn torn yes yeah yes
tearing okay i neva knew we had that and
so the notes let us denote so why
doesn't this a torn frequency I mean
torn I'm sorry why doesn't that allow
does it allow if I just say image effect
of this I mean it has a bunch of
defaults presumably it does yes I don't
know hold on let me just to make
something here um what should I make I
should make a contour plot of x squared
minus y squared
[Music]
and I just you're getting rid of all the
ticks and some of the right hand talk
the next time I tear is it'll tear
differently but by the way this
documentation doesn't make it clear that
you can just do torn frame on its own
right right it's so many of these all of
the effects on the top as well can be
given on their own and they have
defaults for their arguments I don't
want to repeat this is already a long
list of effects I don't want to repeat
Oliver no I'm fine but I mean and you
should make a comments here that you
know any effect here can be given just
as you know it can be alighted right you
should make some comment that says that
okay and also is it clear yeah I mean
hopefully this will make it clear that
you can't do that illusion but we don't
want to rely on those examples we should
have it in the main main discussion all
I don't know do we want to be slightly
more specific than just some methods
right because the way the last note I
think it's the last note
yeah I think this is this is in the deep
in the and the noise so today
all right let's any mood today
yeah that's a punny mood right okay
let's move on extensions to thread a nap
thread you need me for the rest of them
no you're free to go surely thank you
thanks a lot bye okay mmm right so we
started talking about this and then we
decided we'll need a meeting where we're
not already well over time to discuss it
so here we are having it as item okay
map thread should work on Association as
the statement
and why would this not be a good idea
I mean map that doesn't mean anything
when it's fed an association as the
top-level object well currently map
thread doesn't mean anything when it's
handed anything other than a list yeah
but I think that this case I mean these
nice and net objects I mean having
handing map they're a plus is almost
certainly in error I suppose but there
are certainly plenty of cases where you
want to hand it you know an S really
really what such a case well cuz you
know you have your own container and you
know but but I think that those
containers a minority compared to lists
and associations but that doesn't make
it less useful so for example Richard
has an ancient bug or suggestion or
something from working on the Alpha
parser where he really wanted map
threads to work on in arbitrary objects
and not just lists at least if I'm
remembering correctly well I personally
think that's a minority case I mean we
maybe can make it work but I think the
case is much more interested in the
Association case
what's the reason that we shouldn't have
map thread work on associations well
this example looks fine those are two
conforming associations here now what
happens oh yet so next well right that's
right that's still a list right it's a
list of associations so it's doing the
same thing I presume it's doing
[Music]
it's that okay I'm confused now I'm not
sure if it's doing default behavior for
association or but certainly the
outermost head is list they think but
one of the thing is we couldn't
necessarily agree on what what the shape
of the result should be but um by the
way let me just sum some comments from
my live stream from sander here
wondering if it is an idea to reveal the
versions of options like you just showed
such that one can take into account if
their code is compatible with older
versions is this possible I don't quite
understand that what did what did we
just show I don't know what will we M oh
no this is business this this thing here
this what is this this is a and this is
part of this is part of the Wolfram
language data function I'll say I mean
that's the question he's asking is if if
the it's really hard it's really hard to
say if something changes version to
version you know was it just an
optimization etcetera etcetera etcetera
I think he might have been referring to
the source page where we actually mark
what versions things were less modified
oh oh oh yeah don't we have don't we I
mean we have some of that information
right we have we have things that
changed in this version but we don't
have you know that is an interesting
point I mean that is actually an
interesting point we should bring that
up in the next Doc's meeting because we
do have all that stuff tagged we just
have never bothered to reveal it I mean
we have the thing at the bottom of the
page that says you know introduced in
updated in but we we actually do have
the full tagging information throughout
the document
um that is a real
stupid set of related links isn't it I
think so mm-hmm
mix cos related links a bad name
okay I mean these are all things you
might use in customizing your word cloud
I think or many of them are now I say
well okay it does have word clouds in it
they're enough okay um yeah okay so can
we make sure that's in the next Doc's
meeting yep please Thanks
okay as a question of our open CB
gpu-accelerated effects for image
effects I'm afraid we let shadi escape
so we can't answer that question here um
although if you can send that question
along okay and another question is any
discussion of updates to the packet
manager packet system yes yes yes yes we
are working on an in fact I just
requested a meeting today in fact that
will probably be um we'll probably
livestream that meeting will probably be
in the next few days um and if question
was about any plans for a word cloud 3d
I don't know what a word cloud 3d would
do I think a word cloud 3d would just be
totally confusing is there really a
value in a word cloud 3d I mean you
don't usually see words in I mean yeah I
don't I don't really believe in that I'd
like maybe somebody can make a sample of
that and put it in the function
repository um let's see um
yeah this is a question about the packet
repository and update installing from
github and so on yeah we're we're
thinking about it working on it it's
absolutely in the plan for the next few
months um okay
map thread on ragged arrays would be
nice it works for map after all comments
some ride I'm just gonna use sudo first
names ride saying that um well what
would it mean okay so let's go back to
what we were looking at before here
so this is a conforming map thread and
we know what it does but now what is the
non conforming map thread do are you
telling me it fails here yes okay which
this I think is correct so if you give
it a list of unequal lists of unequal
lengths what does I mean some of the
merging functionality has ways of
dealing with and and things like join
across absolutely have ways of dealing
with missing stuff so for example we
could imagine for map thread as for
merge does merge have an option for
dealing with um what to do with the
missing case somebody is insisting that
I look at the oh what a 3d word cloud is
okay well that's a 3d worked out in
motion is that really useful and it
looks cool
oh I see that's probably something I can
stop
actually I think we can do this now that
I think about it I think we can do um I
think if you do um let me do this if I
say
let's see what happens if I say random
word 40 and then I say feature space
plot 3d of that I'm pretty sure I will
get a 3d collection of words there
yeah I do every 3d collection of words
now having it be having it be something
where those are densely packed words I
haven't a clue um all right well you can
certainly give that suggestion to shadi
there seem to grid these examples of
where other people have done 3d word
clouds I have to say I'm less than
convinced um
this is this is clearly an example of a
somewhat meaningfully arranged set of
words why possum to opossum spit I have
no idea of opossum spit but why bypass
and possum are near to each other I have
no idea um but I mean this is using um
now some things that are actually not
totally ridiculous the third but they're
near each other
okay um let's come back to map thread
let's see we've got an example of map
thread here that ride has sent through
let's look at what the Stars
yeah okay so that's that's some that is
nominally conforming
what does this do without the minus one
at the end
okay then it works
what is the minus one doing and my
question is the minus one is a level
spec he's tried not right this is try
was it too
well try place too right
no map thread only takes integer level
specs okay that's too deep I mean if
this is only one level thing anyway no
it's not
it's Rachel range of five okay so what
are you telling me I should do here so
that one works right because it's take
because it's at level one and so why
doesn't it work at level two reads a
range of five on its own my consumer
does
I mean it's crying ground yeah but so
what you're telling me if I say here if
I said table range of five comma five or
whatever then you're telling me this
would work yep you're right okay so I
mean I agree it's pretty gratuitous that
it doesn't work in that ragged case it's
not exactly ragged everything conforms
just doesn't global not globally square
I mean it is well it's ragged when it
comes to rated at level 2 it is ragged
right it's not conformed globally level
2 is ragged but it's consistent
raggedness yes it's consistent at level
2 right ok so my question is we have
functions that emerge doesn't entry one
of them that that decide what to do when
you combine Association
and one of the keys and one of the
association's is missing what is that
how do we do that certainly join across
has that capability what else has that
capability to I'm saying I mean because
because in this case here I could
imagine something which says here's what
to fill in for the missing key I mean
lookup has that ability also right but
so then what are the dimensions of the
result the dimensions of the union of
the keys I would think so I don't know
that that's useful I mean right well so
you think okay so first look there are
two questions here one is map thread
applying to associations I claim that's
a no-brainer and we should just do it
second level is map thread applying to
heads other than lists and associations
I'm skeptical about that one and do not
think we should do it right now and the
third thing is raggedness which I think
raggedness is a whole nother level of
issue and it is you know without some
mechanism for what to do by default
raggedness seems hard to make sense of
do you agree in other words I said
without what which part the whole thing
or just the part of it raggedness
the part of that raggedness my claim is
that the general case of raggedness is
hard to make sense of let me give you an
example okay so let's say I add to this
something which has something like this
okay where I'm alighting from the
beginning and so now I you know let me
make it more complicated by reordering
the individual elements and these
associations you know what do we come
out with as a result
you know it's one thing when it when
they are conforming and samely ordered
so to speak right right and right now
that doesn't work if you reorder like
that's you know one right above where
you're typing where there's no missing
keys or anything okay so you're saying
if I reverse that this is not gonna work
look right just like it doesn't expose
right I mean honestly I think the case
that we should make work immediately is
this case where there is an outer
association this seems to me to be a
no-brainer everything else seems to me
you know has issues what argument does
eff get called within that first case or
what would you expect this one here
mm-hmm does it get one three or does it
get an association K 1 goes to 1 K 2
goes to 3 it gets the Association right
it has to be the Association it's the
direct analog of it's exactly what the
you know it's like a transpose of the
thing does transpose work on this what
does transpose do on this okay by
default it does not it's not the most
brilliant error message okay
you know that error message should be
updated well we should finish the
implementation of allowed heads it's
probably more okay but in case in this
case you know coma with the specified
allowed heads or some such other thing
to make it clear that there's a way out
other than changing that structure all
right yes but like I said we should
finish the implementation of allowed
heads before advertisement our message
fair enough fair enough okay I think
we've we've come to a conclusion the
only thing we're gonna do right now is
the Association case and we're not gonna
worry about raggedness yet okay let's
take a look at this inconsistency
between stake and string take oh this is
a can of worms this is what up to means
what is this this is the fact okay so
string take just like so the issue here
is if I were to do characters of this
and then I was to say take of that I
would get that seems perfectly
consistent okay now what now you're
saying that if I say string take what's
the inconsistency here well well the
fact that the up well there are two
there are multiple inconsistencies one
is the fact that string take of up to of
20 then gives you that other I'm sorry I
just gonna come back to map thread again
we didn't consider the case of deeper
map threads at level two for example and
as Sandra on the live stream is pointing
out there's really no good reason but it
shouldn't work I mean the requirement
for global rectangularity seems quite
out of place that is
well it's only required to be
rectangular up to the depth you've
specified
yes but questions that required and
that's the bug that Richard filed I was
wrong to say that he had filed the bug
or a suggestion about about non list
heads yeah I mean I just think this is
wrong I think this is a bug this case
here should just work I mean that that
is conforming every every requested F is
conforming I think that's simply a bug
and I can give you the bug number what
is it 7 208 4 it's not embarrassingly
low um that's an old finely aged bug um
ok when is it from a decade ago yep
lovely ok well I think it's I still
think it's a bug and I think we should
look at fixing it um ok anyway let's go
on to the string take okay so what's the
inconsistency what's the problem here
the question is well if you looked at
the example so you could see
okay so string take list up to 20 right
I think the claim is that you expect to
get a single character there and you
instead got the full prefix of the
string right and if you look at what
take does take this and allow that
specification mmm I see so what take
would do in this case so something just
to be clear without the brace here up to
20 is happy right because that's the
same thing as one can't list one comma
up to 20 okay fine so this case here
it's similarly happy okay so the cases
are braced up to 20 is that is that the
only case or is there more than is there
more than that case there is the case
okay
is it documented or not it's not
documented okay so maybe it's just a bug
well I can't imagine why this should do
this but this particular thing it seems
just wrong to me try it try it with teh
right look at what take does with it
just gives an arrow doesn't it yes you
know I I agree
I don't see why string cake doesn't do
the same thing okay okay let me just
think about this for one second though
what else could it do so first point is
whatever it does it should return one
character the only question is whether
there is a meaning to saying up to 50 I
mean the only meaning I can see is you
either return character number 50 or you
return the last character that doesn't
make any sense doesn't make any sense
right I think this should just be an
error okay which was basically my
position but since there was some
discussion okay fine all right right so
this is open discussion you said we
should have for discussion about example
data so here's your opportunity to
discuss you know who's here who's
relevant to that I mean I think it's
what's relevant is the various
repositories
okay so I guess the question so then my
question to you is what kind of
discussion were you looking to have um I
don't remember but but I think the issue
is should example data be turned into
something that is in a repository you
know what is the future how is example
day to document it right now it's pretty
kludgy I mean you know to me I kind of
think example data I mean it's possible
that what we should do is just have an
example repository you know this is
pretty random and kludgy at this point
in my view it's very useful but um right
and and it autocompletes
which is an advantage it has over you
know some example repo or well blow the
trees don't autocomplete at the present
time they certainly it is in the plan to
make the moto complete and by the way
solution with that something maybe you
could check into I mean certainly
example data is useful the question is
whether I mean that by the way we could
still have something called example data
just like we have things called you know
net model they just are backed by a
repository so what I'm saying I mean
what I'm thinking here is that that's
the right thing to do to back this with
it I mean yeah I mean whether it wants
to be a separate repository or whether
it's part of the data repository I don't
really know um
I mean there's an argument that it's
really its own repository because these
things are really Toya examples but
nevertheless useful I think this maybe
is the wrong group but that will be what
I would initially favor is an example
repository
um and call on the livestream is
commenting the example they chose useful
as it is I agree I agree no question
it's a question of you know for example
if you want to browse the examples yeah
you can do it to some extent now but it
would be nice if we want to extend this
it will be nice to have browsing that
can be done through you know just an
online gallery um okay so please let's
let's put that in the next repository
meeting discuss that okay type setting
for failure what is this about so
failure behaves differently whether you
use a string the string form type
template or a or a you know string
template type template so what does it
do different what what do you thing here
so this head so does so does both have
the same message with more or less the
same parameters and and they look quite
different don't they they do look
different why do they look different
what's what's well for I said one of
them has positional arguments some other
than has named arguments that's
horrifying right that seems like a bug
to me okay
right but I guess the question is which
way do we want to resolve this well fair
enough let's look at that okay but
actually comments on the live stream
about auto completion
yeah Karl is asking about the analog of
test image Carlina is oh boy
Lina I think has been retired but Tim I
think she's still there just no no no
Lina is still in our Lina is still used
here but I would say in the world at
large Lina has been retired I mean she's
still an example data but we don't use
her great ok fine who's become the new
Lina it's a good it's a good one of
those celebrity placement things um I'm
surprised none of these celebrity agents
as this has jumped on that bandwagon
come the next image test case um I mean
it ought to be worth it at five thousand
dollars or something right so what no no
it's just exposure right if you're it
has to be somebody who's known just by
one name um no no I'm saying we could
sell out oh you know charge people to be
included in an example data right um I
wonder what the resource that your
current would look like a for Lina I I
think we have a bunch of those things in
the data repository we have a test
images example images in the data
repository and see yeah I mean this type
of thing you know that would be what
they are law would be
fluffy um which I don't consider to be
terrible I mean yeah it's a it's it's
mildly longer than Lina but not you know
than that um yeah I I'm kind of a
believer in this um but whether we want
to have a separate family of things that
are just examples I'm not sure um I
don't know whether that's take a look is
is Lina available here oops that's
definitely no not there hmm well okay
wrong group of people for this
discussion I think um okay Auto
completions on entities yeah we know
although that is something Sushma you
might try to bring up in um I mean that
one is is all mixed up with local
versions of lectures and pauses and
things which is being worked on um okay
let's see Leila shouldn't necessarily
feedback the input data what if the
image was enormously huge while it's
being shortened um well okay so that's a
fair point but I mean okay so the issue
is there's some bug that causes these to
not okay so basically this so what the
the name parameters one is essentially
behaving like template apply the one
that looks more like the the positional
one is behaving the way message would
behave right so in other words that this
I mean points on the live stream that I
think of not unreasonable is you got
careful what you actually disgorge in
another message because if the thing you
disgorges 100 megabytes in size it's
going to cause trouble right so the
issue is really what is the rendering
what what is this rendering is this some
kind of string I mean what do we know
what the rendering type is for this one
I think it's just using text string so
some reason it's not using text string
no it's using while it's using thumbnail
on the image in a combination with short
and shallow
it seems clue tree seems like it should
be it's the general thing that gets
applied to everything that every message
right so if you did message with you
know if you created a message with with
that template or if you did you know
well so what should i do I should do
message and then um a non-count message
or something general why doesn't that
autocomplete by the way that's another
autocomplete missing autocomplete okay
well the messages get loaded sort of on
demand right so yeah but we still have
saw the table of them um why didn't this
work because it should have been a
sequence not a list of arguments boy
right so if you're a place okay so I
will just put the fluffy guy in there
it's kind of nice to see the fluffy
thing so you're saying that that was
using thumbnail so it won't de blown up
memory right I mean because it's such an
attractive and fluffy dog I like seeing
it there but I don't know the general
case and what's this export underneath
doing that's well that's the tag right
the first argument at the failures tag I
see I see I see that's just the
formatting of the of the thing which is
not magnificent either I mean you know
arguably that's too big a thumbnail I
mean if I put this random random image
of 600 600
let's see if that thumbnails are down
what I think that wants to be the second
one comma 600 600 interesting why well
yeah that's weird I mean do we actually
believe that there's thumbnailing going
on well let's find out if I do this and
I pick that up and I ask how big is that
um
that's really mysterious all right let's
try 300 or something here that is very
mysterious as well well okay it's
Thunder loading - 75 75 just probably
the default if you just do a random
image well it's what happened here that
looks like a bug and Carl on the live
stream is is some pointing out well a
couple people here are pointing out
crashing to do with mistakes in image
and related gradual slow going happens
when you have a data set full of failure
messages so I mean that the real
question is is failed our failure
message is properly protected in such a
way that they can't get big and it
sounds to me like there's some testing
that needs to be done that and and this
is certainly a mystery what happened
here
I'm suspicious about this one I wonder
if if if shallow is going in and mucking
with the image well so look this has to
be tracked down um I mean this is
basically a bug fix but I think the
bottom line here is I think it's it's
nice to show the images and things if we
can but I think the important thing I
think it should be a little bit smaller
than this but can probably choose that
but I think I mean I would make it like
40 by 40 or something
um but most important is to do the
testing to make sure that nothing can
escape and become big
[Music]
right so whatever failure is doing make
sure
and whatever templating it's doing make
sure it can never become big thinking
about it well let's find out if there's
a problem with that
so it's just out of curiosity Stephen
what happens if you click the button to
have it save the data in the notebook on
that first failure so the feather again
what so when you did the 600 of 600
right you know so does that change the
typesetting if you click that or
shouldn't okay
no it just did something absolutely
stupid here I mean it's stored it but it
stored it in a way that I can't even get
access to well sure you can you can copy
it out and do like rest or something on
it or list it
um write the failures so they're gone
it's a dis failure allow property
extraction yeah so you could yeah use
message parameters on it now I think you
need the way you need the Box so we need
the Box percent you want shift command l
oh boy okay so let's look at image
dimensions of that I'm deeply suspicious
this right that's the right cuz you
stored the whole input in the summary
box
so this says something very wrong going
on here I mean message parameter this is
exactly right I mean other than perhaps
the image right you are confusing
typesetting in full form
right what that button did was store the
full form in the summary box so it could
be extracted and that random image is in
fact in failure
I mean failure doesn't have any
significant evaluation it's not going to
go and change what its parameters are
yeah um okay listen
look I we have to go to another meeting
here but but um can we please do the
investigation of what is escaping and
becoming large in the actual failure
object as it is being formatted okay
something is clearly wrong there let's
go find those bugs and then discuss
whether we have designer suits what is
this I mean where is this coming from
this escaping and becoming large well
people are claiming that's happening but
also we can see why would this do that
image you know and go back at zero why
wasn't it just producing a thumbnail and
I'm 99% sure that the answer to that is
that the shallow is smoking with TM okay
fine then that's a bug because shallow
was built in nineteen nineteen eighty
eight long before we had images and it's
probably not dealing with images
correctly okay I bet that's what's
happening I bet you're right it but it's
going into the structure of the image
and doing something crazy with it that
makes perfect sense actually that's
what's happening and that should be
fixed I mean it just shallow should be
taught about images probably or or we
should use something other than shallow
in in simplifying the message but I
think probably shallow should be talked
about images and I you know images
aren't no entry so that you know there
will be a problem there all right listen
we have to wrap up here for people on
the live stream we're actually going to
go to another live stream meeting about
historical entities and I will be there
soon um okay talk to y'all soon